[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES DUKE: So my
name is James Duke.
I'm in our professional
services group in Google Cloud,
specifically in our strategic
cloud engineering group.
I'm here with my
colleague, Shahid.
SHAHID MASUD: I'm Shahid.
I'm also part of the
professional services
group, also a SCE--
Strategic Cloud Engineer.
JAMES DUKE: And we're
going to talk to you today
a little bit about beginning
the journey-- embarking on,
sorry, the journey towards
containerizing your workloads.
So there's a few different
pieces to this talk,
so we just want to talk
through some of the things
that we're actually going
to cover during the session.
So the first thing
we want to talk about
is what is a container,
what does it give you,
and we'll cut through
some of the jargon,
get to some of those buzzwords.
Explain what some of those are.
We'll cover a little bit about
the business benefits-- what
does containerization get you?
Why would you do
containerization?
What can you do that
you couldn't do before?
And a little bit
about a roadmap--
how do you get from
essentially no containerization
to full containerization
and how would you
start at any point
along that journey.
And so we're going to take
you through those things.
We're going to try and do a
very conversation style here--
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: --between the
two of us, which hopefully
should keep things interesting.
So why don't we start off with
a little bit about containers?
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
So yeah, so let's
start with, what
is the big idea
behind containers?
Why do we need them and
how do they help us?
So you may have heard
a lot of buzzwords
associated with containers.
So what we're
trying to do here is
make you understand why these
are associated with containers.
So we'll revisit them
once you've understood
what containers really are.
So this is the sort of layman's
definition of containers,
so not very technical but
technically correct still.
So containers is about
two capabilities.
The first thing is, the
container technology
allows you to package your
application and everything
that application needs--
could be the configuration,
any libraries that it needs,
any runtimes-- like if
you have Java or Python,
it needs a runtime to
run the application--
so packaging all that
together into one bundle,
and that bundle is
called an image.
So the first capability is the
ability to create that image.
And then the second
part is ability
to run that image as a process
in an isolated environment.
So isolated means that
it's sort of cut off
from other processes running on
the same host and the resources
it can use is limited.
It cannot just run away
with all the resources.
So to understand that
a little bit more,
let's look at the
history of containers
as well as how do applications
typically run on a host.
So the operating system is a key
component running on a computer
and it has a number
of components.
The core part of the OS is
called the kernel and that's
the minimum sort of software
you need to run on a computer
and be able to use it.
Then you need additional--
you might need system modules,
you might need utilities, tools
that support your application
or help you manage that machine,
but the kernel is the core.
That's the minimum
thing that you need.
So when the applications
sort of run,
they are sharing a lot
of these resources.
They might be using
shared libraries.
They can bring their own, but
they might be sharing libraries
with other applications that
are running on the same host.
Similarly, they are time-slicing
the resources, the CPU,
and sharing the memory as well.
And if one process runs
away with the memory,
it can starve the
other processes
running on that machine.
So when you're sharing a host
with regular applications,
these are some of the
issues that can creep up.
The other thing that can happen
is that the shared libraries--
different applications may
need different versions
of those libraries,
so if one application
changes the library
that's installed,
it can interfere with
other applications.
So you have things like, hey,
this ran fine on my machine,
or this runs fine
in development,
and you take it to test
and it starts failing
and you can't figure
out what's going on.
So to get around that, you
have a number of options.
The first option is--
JAMES DUKE: Before we jump
into the virtualization piece,
I'm seeing the post-lunch
coma happening here,
so let's get a little bit
of audience participation
and get some energy back
into the-- it's not really
a room, but the booth, I guess.
So who here has
used a container?
Excellent.
Who here has built a container?
OK.
Who's used a contain
orchestration
system, like Kubernetes or--
yeah?
Oh, that's a good number.
That's a good number.
Who has moved an application
from like a VM environment
to a containerized environment?
OK, good.
Good.
Excellent.
So that tells me one thing--
we're right in the sweet spot
here.
We can cover this
[INAUDIBLE] about containers,
and then we're going
to spend the majority
of the time talking about the
journey towards getting there.
So excellent.
And I'm already seeing more
smiles and energy in the room,
so that's good stuff.
Let's get stuck
into virtualization.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
JAMES DUKE: So Shahid
talked just a little bit
about the kind of
the old school way,
where we have an operating
system and libraries and all
that kind of stuff.
The next step on the
journey is virtualization.
So we're not quite at
full containers yet,
but we have the
ability to break up
a physical machine,
a physical host,
into a number of
virtual hosts, which
solves a number of
those problems, right?
We have limits on
CPU and RAM usage.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
JAMES DUKE: We have
isolation between things.
But there's a lot
of overhead, right?
Because now, as you see here,
four kernels for four VMs.
It takes a long time
to boot a kernel,
a kernel uses a lot of overhead,
actual physical resources
on the host, and
so there is a limit
to how much of the actual
usable computing power
you get out of a machine when
you're using virtualization.
Oh, and they're also
slow to stop because you
have the boot of a kernel.
Booting the kernel
can take a long time,
so if you want to
spin up a new VM,
these are time
components of that
which will reduce the speed
at which you can scale.
So it becomes a
limit on scaling.
So how do we solve that problem?
Well, one approach
is containers.
SHAHID MASUD: And so
container is another type
of virtualization, essentially.
What we're doing is
we're sharing the kernel.
So we're not dividing the actual
host into virtual machines.
We're just setting up some
boundaries around processes,
and hence the word container.
We're containing each process
in its own sort of boundary--
sandbox, if you will--
and using the mechanism
in the kernel to sort of
limit the resources that each
of that process can take.
So it's sort of a
lightweight virtualization
is the other term
that's used as well.
And whatever you do inside
the container stays there,
and any changes that
you make, any libraries
that you bring
into the container,
do not impact any other
processes running on the host.
So let me just show you
guys a running container.
I'll just do a brief demo.
So let me just reconnect here.
It seems like I
got disconnected.
JAMES DUKE: Classic.
SHAHID MASUD: So
what I'm doing is
I have a Google Cloud VM
which can run containers,
so I'm just logging in there.
It seemed like my
session timed out.
And what I'll do is I
will run a container
and I'll show you what
that container looks
like from the point of
view of the container
when you're inside
the container and how
it looks like for the other
processes on the host.
So let's just-- so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use
Docker, which is a container
runtime, and run up an image--
the Nginx image-- that you
guys might be familiar with.
So what I'm doing here is
I am starting that process.
And what you will see is that
that image is now running,
so let's see what that looks
like from the point of view
of the host here.
So I'm going to look
at all the processes
that are running
on this machine,
and what you'll see is that
there are other things running
there but there's
this Docker daemon
and that is running
the Docker runtime--
the container
runtime-- and you'll
see that the Nginx is actually
running in that process tree.
And you can see all
the other processes
that are there as well.
Now what I'll do
is I'll just attach
to that container--
what you can do
is you can attach to a
container and essentially start
a shell command
inside the container.
So that's what I'm doing.
I'm just attaching to that
and executing the bash shell.
So what you'll see is my
command prompt has changed
and now I'm in the
context of that container,
so any commands
that I run here are
running inside that container.
So if I look at
the file system--
it has its own file system--
and if I run that ps command in
here, what you will see is you
will see a very limited
set of processes.
On the host, you saw that you
had all the other processes
that were running on the host,
but from the container's point
of view, it sees itself
as the only process.
So it sees the ps command that
I ran, the shell that I'm in,
and the Nginx, which we
actually wanted to run.
So this shows you how the
processes are isolated.
So from within the container, it
cannot access any of the other
processes and it's sort
of isolated from those.
So that just shows you what
a running container actually
looks like.
So just to recap quickly the
different ways of running
applications, the traditional
way is shared hosts
and we saw the problems
with that-- there's
no isolation between
your applications.
Things that one
application does can
impact the other applications.
You have to prepare the
host to run the application.
Your libraries have to
be a particular version.
If they're not-- if your tools
are not the right version,
you might have issues.
Then on the other end, we
have the virtual machines,
which provide a very
high level of isolation.
You can customize each virtual
machine to the exact specs that
you need but the downside
is that it's expensive
and inefficient and virtual
machines cannot be easily
resized.
You cannot increase the size of
a virtual machine that easily
and it's generally a little
bit harder to manage,
but they do provide
very high isolation.
Containers provide sort of a
middle ground, where it does
provide the isolation you need.
You can install
whatever libraries
you need inside the container
image, and that way,
your application will
have exactly what it needs
and only what it needs.
You don't want to put a lot
of extra stuff in there.
And that way,
there's less overhead
and you can use the same host to
host more than one application.
JAMES DUKE: It's
always the way--
the password's always wrong when
someone else is looking, right?
SHAHID MASUD: Yes.
I had-- yeah.
So yeah, so they provide a good
sort of a middle ground, where
they provide the isolation
that you need but they're
nimble and lightweight.
So with that, we can revisit
some of the buzzwords
and you'll hopefully understand
it a little bit better.
JAMES DUKE: Yeah, so we
promised at the beginning
to cut through the buzzwords.
We just used a whole bunch of
buzzwords in that description,
so let's revisit them and
really nail them down.
We talked a lot
about lightweight.
So containers are lightweight.
You'll hear this a lot.
What we're really
talking about there
is they contain
only what they need.
So when we spin up the VM, we
had all the extra stuff, right?
We had all the things that
the operating system needs,
the kernel, the dependencies,
libraries which likely are
never used by your application.
I can say that doesn't have
any of those things, right?
It just has the bare
minimum you need to run.
SHAHID MASUD: Yes.
Yep.
And that provides an extra
benefit that you don't have any
tools that-- if someone--
to be misused.
It reduces the attack surface.
So if you had some rogue process
running in your container,
it has less tools
at its disposal
to wreak havoc in your VM.
JAMES DUKE: And at
a very simple level,
it uses less resources, which
means you can run more of them.
Right?
You can run more containers
on a given physical host
than you can run VMs on
a given physical host.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: They
are also portable.
You can move them around easily.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: Right?
And we'll show you that once
you've built your image,
you've done the hard part.
And that image is very portable.
Since the image contains
everything you need,
all you really need is
sort of a host to run it.
So you need compute and
memory and you can run it
pretty much anywhere.
JAMES DUKE: And we're going
to focus very much on Google's
platforms today but
that's true, of course,
of all sorts of things.
Right?
You can pick up an
image and move it
to another host, another
platform, another provider.
It just has the ability to
be moved around very easily.
And partially because
of the lightweight,
they're fast, right?
I said earlier,
overhead from a VM,
you have to wait for
the kernel to boot,
which can take a long time.
None of that with a container.
You start a process,
that's how long it
takes to boot the container.
Plus, of course, anything
that the container needs
to do for startup, of course,
but the actual container
itself runs much, much, much
faster than, say, booting up
a VM, which means when you're
doing that portability,
there's no penalty and overhead
of starting up that machine.
You don't have to wait two,
three minutes, whatever
it might be, to shut
down and restart a VM.
It can be just like that.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
So you can scale
up faster as well.
Since you can
share the host, you
can run multiple applications,
so a new host does not
necessarily have to be spun up.
You can use the same host and
quickly start new processes
to take on additional load.
Yep.
JAMES DUKE: That's
the buzzwords.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: Make sense?
Cut through?
Do you feel sufficiently
cut through those buzzwords?
Excellent.
Good stuff.
SHAHID MASUD: All right.
So let's see what it
means for your business.
Why do you want
to run containers?
Now that you have a basic
understanding of what
container technology is.
So we see containers as sort
of an enabling technology.
The benefits will
come after you've
started using containers.
It's sort of a price of
admission, if you will,
or price you have to
pay to be able to use
a lot of the other things.
And once you've
containerized, you
have a wide variety of
things available to you.
You can deploy containers
on bare VMs, what is also
known as infrastructure
as a service,
or you can move to a more
managed service like Kubernetes
Engine, which is typically known
as a platform as a service,
or you can go to App Engine
and serverless offerings that
are now showing up
in the marketplace.
So it allows you to move from
one to the other pretty much
seamlessly and effortlessly.
JAMES DUKE: I think more what
we're sort of saying here
is, all those things that we
just said a moment ago that is
what containers are, those are
the business benefits, right?
Fast, portable, lightweight.
They enable you to do
more things that you just
could not do before.
Right?
So containerization
in and of itself
isn't necessarily the end goal.
And we actually see this a
lot with our customers, right?
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: We have people
who want to come to us
and say, well, I need to
containerize because it's cool,
or I need to containerize
because all of my competitors
are containerizing.
Those are not great
motivations to do this,
because in and of itself, it
doesn't give you anything,
right?
If you took one application
and containerized it, well OK,
great.
It's now a containerized
version of the same thing.
It's what you can do next that
is where the real business
value is and what it enables you
to be able to do and grow into.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
So here are just
some examples of how
you can take the same image and
run it on different products
that Google offers.
And these are completely
portable between one
and the other.
So you can take the
image, just deploy it
to Compute Engine
with a glcoud command.
You can use Kubernetes
kubectl to deploy it
to a Kubernetes Engine cluster.
Or you can deploy the same
image to an App Engine instance.
JAMES DUKE: So that's
three different hosts--
three different targets--
for the same image.
It's really that easy.
Three different
commands and you've
got the same image running
on three different things.
SHAHID MASUD: So you
have more options.
So what do we do
with those options?
What are the different
choices of runtimes
and what do they mean for us?
JAMES DUKE: Right?
It's a change of problem.
Before, we had the
problem of, how
do we make the VM
as good as possible?
Now we have a question of,
where do we put the container?
How do we choose the right
home for that container
to get the maximum value?
The good news is,
if you get it wrong,
it's that easy to change
to a different one, right?
Two commands and you're
back to where you were.
So it's a very low
risk of a decision
to make but it does
mean that we can
use the different advantages
of the different platforms
for the actual business value,
rather than just because it's
what's technically
compatible with what we have.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And the way to look at it is,
if you look from left to right,
the options on the left
end of the spectrum
give you more control
but the downside
is they come with the
overhead of you managing
your own infrastructure.
So you have to
manage your own VMs.
And it's sort of an
overhead but that's
what a lot of organizations
are used to so it's
a more familiar world for you.
So you can start there.
Start with Compute
Engine and run containers
on Compute Engine, and
then you can graduate
to different other offerings.
As you move along
towards the right,
the offerings are more managed.
That means that you have to
spend less resources managing
those offerings.
And for small organizations,
startups, typically they
don't have the extra resources
to manage the infrastructure,
so that's why we see a lot of
startups start on App Engine
and it's geared towards that.
JAMES DUKE: And I'm sure you've
heard that a lot this week
and at prior Next and
other Google events.
We're forever talking about
freeing up your developers
to do what's meaningful, right--
where the actual business
impact is.
Keeping the lights
running on a VM probably
doesn't make your business or
your customer's business money,
right?
What makes the money is building
new innovation-- innovating
new things, creating
new opportunities
for your customers,
for their customers,
and so freeing up your
developers to do that is great.
And all we're trying to say here
is that, by containerizing, we
can get even closer to
that dream of minimizing
the amount of time
and money that we've
spent on these things which
don't generate that business
value.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And sort of the
tradeoff is, as you're
moving towards the right,
you're giving up some control.
When you're running in
a managed environment,
you have to understand the
environment that you're
operating in and maybe change
your application accordingly
to take advantage of that.
So even though staying on a
more self-managed platforms
gives you more freedom,
moving towards the right side
gives you sort of more
flexibility and less overhead.
JAMES DUKE: Exactly.
OK.
So that's a lot
about what containers
are, why you should use them.
Now to the true value here--
how do we get there?
How do we go from
nothing to something
in the world of
containerization?
And the key to
this is, it doesn't
have to be everything
at once, right?
There's no sledgehammer that
fixes this walnut, right?
We want to break
down the problem
into different
components and tackle
each one of those
components one at a time.
And so the first step to
that is, what have I got
and what category
does it fall into?
Inventory and classify.
Now inventory, as I'm sure you
know, is not straightforward.
Doing an inventory
of every application
that you run or your customer
runs is very, very difficult.
So we're not necessarily
suggesting here
that we want to spend all of our
time talking about inventorying
every application right down
to the tiny little ones that
are barely used and
hiding in the corners.
The real meat here is
in the classification.
So find the 80% of
the applications
and then focus in on those
to see which ones of those
we can use in which wave.
And we basically said there
are three groups, right?
Group one, we're talking
about stateless applications--
things where we don't
need to remember what
happened last time around.
So classic example is web front
ends, some microservices, APIs,
but anything where
the current request
doesn't need any contacts
from the prior request.
These are great candidates
for containerization.
Once you've found this group,
this is the first group.
This is the first movers.
This is the thing that
is the easiest to do
and will give you the
most impact straightaway.
So finding this category
is the place where
you want to be to move quickly.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
The second group is what we're
calling the second movers.
These are applications
that have some state
but the state is temporary.
Even if you lose the
state, it's not a big deal,
like, caching is a
great example of that.
When you start a
caching application,
it doesn't have
anything stored in it.
You build up the cache
as the application runs
and then it's useful
that you can look up
things that are cached already.
But if you had to
restart it, yes, you
lose the agility of being
able to look up things
from the cache but it's
not the end of the world.
You can restart and start over.
JAMES DUKE: Yeah, it's
an accelerator, right?
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: They accelerate
performance but the actual data
loss is not critical.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
So other examples
in this category
would be things that have
like a master/slave component
sort of thing where one
instance is the master
and there are separate slaves.
So again, each instance
is not the same.
There is some state that is
sort of unique to each instance.
So those kind of applications
are again a little bit harder
to not containerize
but run effectively
in a containerized environment.
Creating a container
is not as difficult.
The challenge comes from
actually managing it
in a containerized
environment-- running it
in a containerized environment.
JAMES DUKE: And then there's
group three, the hard group--
the stateful applications.
Now you'll hear
lots of people say
don't run stateful applications
in containerized environments.
It's good guidance.
It's not because you
can't and it's not
because there's no
value to doing so.
It's because it's hard
and the value is minimal
compared to the other things.
So any time you find one of
these stateful applications,
that goes in tier three.
It goes in wave three.
Right?
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
JAMES DUKE: It can be done.
SHAHID MASUD: Yes.
JAMES DUKE: Some good
examples-- storage, databases.
Containerizing a MySQL
database is not necessarily
the easiest thing in the world.
It can be done but there's work.
There's process.
And if you think about the
reasons for containerization,
you're talking about ease
of scaling, the performance
savings, things like that.
A database doesn't
lend itself as well
as easily to that as something
like web-front end does.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: And again,
it's very possible.
It can be done.
But it's definitely lower
on the list of priorities
when it comes to investing your
employees' time and your time
in actually building and
changing that application.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And if you think about
it, you can't just
instantiate another
database and expect
it to sort of work seamlessly.
There's a lot of
work that goes on
to make the application
and other things
work across these
kinds of applications.
So the benefits that you
get from containerization
of ability to scale up quickly
and scale down based on demand
is not easily done with
these kind of applications.
So that's why we're
saying that this
would be the lowest priority.
JAMES DUKE: At the
end of the talk,
we'll come back to
some examples of where
you can see this done the right
way that you can go and look at
if you do get to that stage
three, that group three.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
So yeah, so that
was the first part
is to inventory and sort of
classify your applications
into different groups.
The second part
is, how do you now
start containerizing
those applications?
So we'll go through
a number of examples.
And the great thing is
that you could be anywhere
along this journey.
This is typically how
organizations start.
A lot of organizations
might be running
what are call
monolithic applications.
So you have one
sort of application
that has the frontend and the
services, everything, in one
runtime--
maybe like a Java
Enterprise application
that does everything
is an example of that.
So those are typically called
monolithic applications.
And you have a database where
you store some of the state
and then the monolith runs
both your frontend as well as
the application.
So you can containerize it.
So the part to containerize
is that monolith.
And the positives of that
are this proves the concept.
If you're just starting
on this journey,
it shows you that
you can containerize,
and without investing a lot
of effort in re-architecting,
you're proving
that you're getting
familiar with the
containerized world
and proving that
you can manage it.
JAMES DUKE: On the other
hand, as mentioned earlier,
you now just have
the same application
that is containerized.
It's running in a container
but it's pretty much
exactly the same.
So there's actually minimal
benefit to doing this.
The primary piece is
that it's like practice.
It's an easy win, right?
We can take one thing
and say, oh hey, cool.
I know how to containerize
an application.
And there's learning and merit
in doing that in and of itself
but it doesn't really
give you the scalability--
like the chances of that then
becoming very scalable just
by putting it in a
container is very slim.
So you haven't got
those full business
benefits we've been talking
about, but you have proven,
hey, I know how to do this,
I know the technologies,
I know the tools, which
gives you confidence when
we move on to the next type.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
So then the next step
along the journey--
and you may already be here--
is, as we mentioned,
that you have
to take out the stateless
portions of your application
and sort of containerize.
So containerize them separately.
So what we're doing
is this is sort
of a three-tier design where
you have a frontend separate
from your backend and then
you have the database as well.
So this might be the
next logical step,
and in this, you
would again do well
to containerize the
frontend and the backend
separately, in
separate containers.
The box is not meant to
show that you put them
in the same container.
You put them in
separate containers
but that's the portion
of your application
that you should start
looking at containerizing.
And again, the
positives are you can
scale the tiers individually.
If you have a lot of
frontend requests--
people are just maybe browsing
and not interacting with things
that require backend services--
you can scale that up and down,
independent of the services.
Again, the drawbacks
are that you're not
getting the full benefits.
This is still not scalable.
But the great thing
is you're getting
closer to the microservices
architecture, which
I guess everybody loves
that and wants to go there.
So the great thing is that
containerization sort of forces
you towards that architecture.
So going along this
journey, you'll
end up with a number of
microservices along the way.
JAMES DUKE: And each of these
application architectures
we're showing here are
moving increasingly
away from the
monolith, increasingly
towards the microservices model.
And the idea here is
we show in each stage
where we can apply that
containerization technology
and how that enables us to
move further down that path.
So it may be that you
and your customers
have started off at
the pure monolith
or any one of these
architectures down the line.
What you'd want to say is
there is a journey and a path
forward that you can enter
in at any of those places.
So this is one, the three tier.
The next one would
be if you have
a transitional
microservices architecture.
So it's like a traditional
three-tier application
but now some of
those backend pieces
are broken out as
their own service.
So in this particular
example, service A--
maybe it's authentication, maybe
it's the item library catalog,
whatever it might be--
has already been broken
off as its own service.
It hasn't necessarily
already been containerized.
It may be just running
in a VM or a few VMs
or something like that.
That is a great candidate
for containerization.
We're now talking
about the ability
to take that one service
and scale it up and scale it
down very easily, move it
across different platforms,
reduce overhead, increase
security, et cetera, et cetera,
and we're creating by doing
this pattern that we can then
use as we move further down
the microservices path.
You can think of it
as a toe in the water
of microservices
architecture, all right?
You don't have to touch
the existing monolith.
That remains
unchanged so there's
minimal risk in the application.
So if this is a
business-critical application
that's actually
generating the revenue,
there's minimal risk
in doing these changes.
However, that's a good thing
and a bad thing, right?
Because now we still
have the monolith.
There's presumably a
reason why you want
to move away from the monolith.
Whatever that reason is,
this doesn't solve, right?
It's a step in the
right direction
but you're still left with those
problems that you had before.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And the other great
thing with this approach
is that now you're not
re-architecting the whole thing
at once.
Your existing applications
continues to run and be useful
and you're transitioning
slowly to this new architecture
so you have fewer disruptions.
And you're learning--
as you're getting
comfortable in this
new architecture
and the containerized
world, you're learning
and it's sort of
spread out over time
so your risk is reduced as well.
JAMES DUKE: Exactly.
And then the next step
towards microservices, you
can add an API gateway.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
And then what you can do is--
one pattern that we see that
is very useful if you're
going in this kind of a journey
is to add an API gateway.
API gateway sort of
hides the services that
are at the backend
from your clients,
which includes your frontend
as well as some clients
might directly be
connecting to your services,
like if you have a mobile
application that runs
that is not a browser-based.
It's a native application.
It may need to call services,
and if it goes through the API
gateway, then it doesn't need
to know exactly how the services
are laid out at the backend.
So it has a number
of advantages,
so that might be the next
logical step that you introduce
into your architecture--
add a gateway, which
will hide the details of the
endpoints of actual services.
And as you move them
around, it doesn't
matter whether the
response is coming
from your monolith or just the
new service that you've added.
The clients don't have
to know that detail.
And that way, you can easily
change the service endpoints.
You can introduce
a new service, you
can move it around,
and so on and so forth.
The drawback here
is that you need
to build this sort of gateway.
And this is a common
pattern, though,
that we see in the industry.
So there are a lot of
examples out there and taking
this step shouldn't be daunting.
JAMES DUKE: And it's not
wasted effort, right?
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: In the dream
state fully microservices
architecture, you may still
want to have the API gateway.
So this is not work you're
going to do it and throw away.
It's work which is
useful later on.
SHAHID MASUD: Yep.
All right.
And then you can
build on that pattern
and you can scale
out your services.
You can keep taking services
out of your monolith
and keep putting them into new
service-oriented architecture.
And this is an approach that
a lot of people recommend,
even if you're starting
with a new application.
Even if you have a
greenfield application,
there are two schools of
thought in microservices.
Some people believe
that you shouldn't
start with microservices.
You should build them
as you need them.
As your use cases
are seen, you truly
realize what services you need.
If you sort of theoretically
start with some services
that you think you
might need, that
may not be the right division.
So this sort of
allows you to move
into this microservices
architecture at your own pace.
JAMES DUKE: And in
the dream world,
this legacy backend
goes away, right?
The dream utopian
future is everything
to microservice in a full
microservice architecture.
The reality in the field,
at least that we're seeing,
is that doesn't really work.
There's always some element,
or usually some element,
that needs to remain.
Maybe it's some hardware that
you can't move to the cloud
or move to your microservices.
Maybe there's some
legacy software
which has some licensing
requirement that you
can't meet in the new world.
But what we're talking
here is the 90% to 95%
of the functionality
of the application
moves into these microservices.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: Now does anybody
recognize this pattern?
Has anyone seen this before?
Does anyone know what
we're talking about?
Shout out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES DUKE: Louder.
My hearing is terrible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES DUKE: Yeah?
You've seen this in the field?
I'm going to go to my plant,
who I know knows the answer.
AUDIENCE: Strangler pattern.
JAMES DUKE: Strangler pattern.
Exactly.
So those of you
who have seen this
before, the principle goes--
if you have a great
big tree that's
been standing for
100 years and there's
vines growing around it, each
one of these microservices
is a vine.
Eventually, when the vines are
big enough and complex enough
and strong enough, if the
tree dies and rots away,
the vines remain in its place.
And it's a really nice
analogy for this, right?
We build the microservices
around the monolith
until we have replaced
all of its functionality,
or 95% of its functionality,
at which point
we can shut it down.
Turn it off or turn the
vast majority of it off,
and we are left with this true
microservices architecture.
And in our professional
services group,
in our application
development specialty group,
we use this all the time.
This is our go to market, so
to speak, with our customers,
where we will pitch
this idea and follow it
through with them,
where we can actually
start to replace
the giant monolith
with beautiful microservices
architecture built
around containers with
containerization, Kubernetes,
GKE in most cases, where we
can actually start to remove
and replace that monolith.
SHAHID MASUD: And this gives you
another sort of insight into,
when you have these
microservices running sort
of independently, you can
choose different products
to run them in.
You might run your frontend
in App Engine, for example,
and run your backend services
in Kubernetes engine.
You might have some services
deployed as Cloud Functions.
So it gives you the ability
to sort of pick and choose
the appropriate technology to
run your actual application in.
So that's sort of another--
JAMES DUKE: Exactly.
SHAHID MASUD:
--idea around that.
Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: And you
get all the benefits
we talked about in the
microservices architecture,
right?
Scale different services,
implement new services,
replace existing ones.
It really gives you those three
things we talked about at the
beginning-- the lightweight,
the fast, and the portable.
Whilst they are
elements of containers,
they are what we're striving for
in a microservices architecture
as well.
The two things I often hear,
our customers will say,
well microservices
and containers
means the same thing.
It's not the same but it's
very closely related, right?
The two go together hand
in hand very nicely.
You can do one
without the other.
You could do containers
without microservices,
you could do microservices
without containers,
but the two when
they're done together
gives you the most value.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I guess the third
step is to sort of reap
the benefits of this new
state and enjoy, I guess,
the microservices architecture.
JAMES DUKE: Exactly.
So I mentioned earlier that
once we got towards the end,
we would talk
about some examples
of stateful applications
running in Kubernetes.
We actually have a whole
bunch of other things.
So something that
we are seeing out
in the world with our
customers and with our partners
is that there is a
large request and desire
to have example applications
and workshops to go with them so
that a customer or a
business can understand
how do I do x with GKE.
And when I say x, I
mean different things.
So how do I run an application
in GKE in production?
How do I handle
networking in GKE?
How do I run stateful
applications in GKE?
And the more we've seen
those questions come out,
the more we've
come to understand
that we needed something from
the professional services
viewpoint in addition to
everything that we had.
So we came up with
Project Helmsman.
And I'm very pleased to announce
that today is the first day
that the Project
Helmsman code is released
into public open-source.
You can all go check
this out straight after.
In fact, you could check it
out right now if you wanted to.
Straight after
the talk, you will
be able to see it
at this URL here.
The idea is we've come
up with code samples,
and there's a few
folks sitting here
in the room who have been very
heavily involved with this,
so thank you very
much to you all.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: We now
have open-source proof
of concepts for all those things
I just mentioned and more.
We have matching presentations
which are available
to Google's partners
today, with more to come,
that allow you to walk through
a one-day or half-day workshop
of any number--
any one of these
particular things.
So if you or your
customer has a question,
how do I actually use GKE in
production, we have an example
and we have a workshop
to work through.
There will be more--
watch this space.
We will be releasing more
and iterating on these
as time goes on, but I
hope that this generates
a great deal of value for you
and for your customers that
enable you to really start
to use GKE in the way
that we hope it can be.
SHAHID MASUD: And we've tried
to take real-world scenarios.
I know these are sort
of samples and examples
but we've tried to sort
of root them in reality
and what actually
the customers need.
So we have also covered a
lot of hybrid scenarios,
where you might be still running
some applications on-premise
outside of the
cloud, so it covers
a lot of different scenarios.
So I hope you find it useful.
Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: Absolutely.
[MUSIC PLAYING]